Trascrizione: Piero Cavallo
Revisore: Veronica Viscardi
“The danger of AI is not
that is going to rebel against us,
is that it’s going to do exactly
what we ask it to do.”
Queste sono le parole di Janelle Shane,
esperta di intelligenza artificiale.
Le ha proprio pronunciate
durante un Ted Talk, qualche anno fa.
Io sono assolutamente d’accordo con lei.
Il vero pericolo
non è l’intelligenza artificiale,
bensì ciò che le chiediamo di fare.
A differenza di Janelle però,
non vi parlerò di esperimenti divertenti
con i gusti di gelato.
Vi racconterò invece come l’uso
dell’intelligenza artificiale
sia spesso discriminatorio,
a meno che non le chiediamo
di fare il contrario.
Un algoritmo di per sé infatti
non è né buono né cattivo.
Semplicemente registra, processa ed esegue
dati e istruzioni forniti da esseri umani
in carne ed ossa.
Come fa esattamente?
Semplificando, è simile
a come siamo abituati a fare
nella vita di tutti i giorni
da oltre 2.000 anni.
Lo fa attraverso delle categorie.
È il modo più facile che conosciamo
per interpretare situazioni complesse.
Il nostro cervello è strutturato
per procedere per categorie
e ogni categoria genera
quello che oggi definiamo bias.
Ma quello che le nostre mamme
e le nostre nonne,
ben prima dell’avvento dell’informatica,
chiamavano semplicemente pregiudizio.
Già nel quarto secolo avanti Cristo,
Aristotele propose 10 categorie
per descrivere l’Essere.
Prendete me: Donatella Sciuto.
Mi si potrebbe rappresentare come:
un essere di genere femminile,
secondo quella che Aristotele
definiva “sostanza”;
che misura un metro
e 60 centimetri, quantità;
che ama la lettura e buon vino, qualità;
figlia di Franca,
sorella di Gaetano, relazione;
che vive a Milano, luogo;
che da oltre 20 anni insegna
al Politecnico di Milano,
tempo e posizione;
che nella vita si occupa
di calcolatori, azione;
che ha una casa, possesso;
e che ama i viaggi, passione.
Ecco qua, mi presento.
Perfettamente inserita
in una serie di caselline.
Categorizzata.
Ma questo è solo un modo per descrivermi;
ce ne sarebbero mille altri.
Potrei dirvi che io sono
molto più di così,
che questa definizione è limitante,
è irrilevante, arbitraria.
Nel corso del tempo
molti pensatori hanno messo in discussione
le categorie proposte da Aristotele,
perché categorizzare, classificare
significa necessariamente
adottare una visione limitata del mondo,
delle persone e delle cose.
Tuttavia, questo è l’unico modo
che conosciamo per dare ordine alla realtà
seppur generando dei pregiudizi.
Ne siamo consapevoli.
Perché dunque gli algoritmi
dovrebbero funzionare diversamente?
Gli algoritmi sono creati dall’uomo
e come tali ne riflettono vizi e virtù.
Attenzione però
a non commettere un errore:
quello di pensare all’algoritmo
in termini antropomorfi.
Quando parliamo
di intelligenza artificiale di algoritmi,
spesso lo facciamo
come se fossero esseri viventi.
Diciamo che imparano,
decidono, si nutrono.
Questo tipo di linguaggio
è un falso amico:
da un lato ci permette
di immaginare più facilmente
la situazione in cui ci troviamo;
dall’altro fa scattare in noi
quel meccanismo secondo il quale
iniziamo a credere che l’algoritmo
sia indipendente e cosciente.
Nulla di più falso.
Questo fenomeno si chiama ELIZA.
Prende il nome da un chat-bot,
un agente intelligente
sviluppato nel 1966 all’MIT.
ELIZA comunicava per iscritto
con i pazienti in psicoterapia.
Ripeteva tutto quello che le raccontavano
sotto forma di domanda.
Dopo un po’ i pazienti iniziarono
a credere che stessero interagendo
con un essere pensante.
Non era così ovviamente e non lo è oggi.
Quando interroghiamo Siri,
quando scuotiamo la testa,
o sospiriamo in segno di disapprovazione
se non ci fornisce
una risposta soddisfacente.
La vera domanda da farsi in questi casi
è se sia possibile o meno
programmare la moralità di un algoritmo,
insegnargli a distinguere
tra il bene e il male.
La risposta è no, chiaramente.
L’algoritmo non è responsabile
delle scelte che compie.
Potremmo invece parlare
di un concorso di colpa,
di una responsabilità condivisa
tra designer, ingegneri e programmatori.
Vi faccio alcuni esempi.
La scienziata afroamericana
Joy Buolamwini,
fondatrice
della Algorithmic Justice League,
si rese conto che il software
di riconoscimento facciale
al quale stava lavorando
con un gruppo di ricercatori dell’MIT
riconosceva tutti i suoi compagni,
ma non lei.
All’inizio pensò a un errore di sistema.
Poi capì che non riconosceva
la pelle scura.
Indossò una maschera bianca
e tutto funzionò alla perfezione.
Ma cosa era successo?
Era successo che l’algoritmo
era stato addestrato
usando esclusivamente immagini
di individui dalla pelle bianca.
Una scelta ben precisa.
A seguito di questo fatto Buolamwini
coniò l’espressione “the coded gaze”,
“lo sguardo codificato”.
È il riflesso delle priorità,
delle preferenze e talvolta dei pregiudizi
di coloro che hanno il potere
di plasmare la tecnologia.
Per questo alcuni gruppi
sono sovra-rappresentati
e altri sono sotto-raffigurati.
Pensate che più del 45% delle immagini
contenute nei database di allenamento
al riconoscimento facciale
sono di provenienza americana.
Cina e India contribuiscono per il 3%,
anche se rappresentano il 36%
della popolazione mondiale.
Per questa ragione, all’immagine
di una donna vestita di bianco,
un algoritmo di computer vision
associa le parole “bride”, sposa,
oppure “wedding”, matrimonio.
Ma a un’immagine
che ritrae una sposa indiana
associa le parole “performance”,
“art” e “costume”.
Bias involontari, ma pericolosi.
Qualche tempo fa, l’algoritmo di Amazon
per la selezione del personale
è stato accusato di sessismo.
Nel 2014, alla ricerca
di ingegneri del software,
Amazon ha commesso l’errore
di addestrare l’algoritmo
sulla base delle assunzioni
degli ultimi dieci anni,
di fatto prevalentemente maschili.
E visto che gli algoritmi predittivi
si basano sull’esperienza,
le donne venivano escluse.
A un anno di distanza,
Amazon ha ritirato il software.
È nei dati iniziali
che si annidano i bias.
I dati che abbiamo a disposizione
possono farci sviluppare un algoritmo
profondamente distorto
o uno profondamente corretto.
Dipende dall'uso che vogliamo farne.
Vi faccio un altro esempio.
Fino a non molti anni fa, le banche
non concedevano prestiti alle donne
a meno che non utilizzassero
il cognome del marito.
Fino al 1965, nessuna donna sposata poteva
rivolgersi a uno sportello bancario.
Supponiamo ora
che io debba istruire un algoritmo
per finanziare un’attività
imprenditoriale femminile
sulla base dei dati degli ultimi 50 anni.
Cosa pensate che accadrà?
“Certo”, direte voi,
“non possiamo cambiare la storia”.
Ma nemmeno ignorarla.
Per questo è fondamentale
che i programmatori e gli ingegneri
tornino a inserire
nei loro percorsi di studio e di carriera
le materie umanistiche,
come la sociologia o la filosofia.
Fino alla metà del ventesimo secolo,
gli scienziati erano filosofi.
Cartesio ancora oggi è più noto
per il suo “Discorso sul metodo”
e meno per la geometria cartesiana.
Di Pascal conosciamo “I Pensieri”,
ma dimentichiamo
la calcolatrice meccanica.
Come ha recentemente scritto Aurélie Jean
nel suo libro “Nel paese degli algoritmi”,
“I filosofi riflettono
su un mondo che gli sfugge,
gli scienziati costruiscono un mondo
in cui si riflettono”.
Spetta quindi agli scienziati garantire
che le evoluzioni tecnologiche
portino con sé emancipazione e progresso.
Spetta poi a tutti noi cittadini
comprenderne i principi di base,
decidere se adottare o meno strumenti
che discriminano parte della società.
Spetta a noi tutti regolarne l'utilizzo.
Adottare quella che Noam Chomsky
definisce “autodifesa intellettuale”.
Alcuni pregiudizi provengono
dalla nostra cultura,
altri dall’ambiente
e altri ancora dalle nostre esperienze.
Sviluppiamo bias cognitivi
fin dall’infanzia,
ma non sempre sappiamo riconoscerli.
Tuttavia, quando questo accade,
abbiamo un’unica scelta da fare:
accettarli o respingerli
nel momento in cui ci vengono proposti
o quando vengono riprodotti.
Lo sapete per esempio
che le assistenti virtuali
sono spesso soggette a molestie verbali?
E che per tutta risposta,
i loro sistemi di intelligenza artificiale
sono programmati per replicare
alle molestie con sottomissione,
tolleranza e osservazioni passive?
Lo dimostra uno studio pubblicato
dall’UNESCO a maggio 2019
intitolato “I’d blush if I could”,
“Arrossirei, se potessi”.
Una voce di donna porta con sé
tutti gli stereotipi del caso.
Un atteggiamento che, in modo volontario
o involontario, accettiamo
e che promuove una cultura
della violenza e dell’ambiguità
che non sono più tollerabili.
E allora facciamoci una domanda:
la ricerca ha un genere?
La situazione potrebbe migliorare
se un numero maggiore di donne
programmasse questi sistemi
di intelligenza artificiale?
Aiuterebbe certamente.
Ma siamo ancora molto lontani
dalla possibilità che accada.
A livello mondiale poco meno del 30%
delle donne sceglie percorsi di studio
nell’ambito dell’informatica,
della comunicazione e delle tecnologie.
In Europa meno di un laureato su cinque
in Computer Science è donna.
In Finlandia, dove esiste
un vero e proprio gender gap paradox,
una delle nazioni dove la parità di genere
sembra più agevolata,
le adolescenti superano
di gran lunga i maschi negli studi.
Ma poi solo una su quattro
sceglie una laurea tecnico-scientifica.
La maggior parte delle donne
è attratta da materie scientifiche
intorno agli 11-12 anni.
Ma a 15 o 16 ne ha già perso l’interesse.
Perché?
Perché l’educazione
ci spinge al conformismo,
all’accettazione sociale.
E allora chiudo con una storia
e con un volto.
Quello di Camille Schrier.
Camille ha 24 anni, due lauree:
una in biochimica e una in biologia.
Al momento frequenta un corso di dottorato
ed è stata eletta Miss America 2020.
In una delle sue tante interviste
ha raccontato che, durante la finale,
mentre le altre ragazze in gara
si mettevano in fila
con scarpette da danza,
lei si è presentata sul palco
con le provette
e con il camice da laboratorio.
“A volte quelle che sembrano debolezze
possono diventare
i tuoi punti di forza”, ha detto.
Questa frase mi ha molto colpita.
Quale sarebbe esattamente la debolezza?
La scienza?
Mi ha molto colpita perché
rappresenta il tipico pensiero femminile,
quello di riconoscersi
nel giudizio degli altri.
Rivela come per molte di noi la scienza
sia ancora qualcosa di cui scusarsi,
come se ci appropriassimo
di ciò che non ci appartiene.
Una debolezza, appunto.
E allora chiedo a tutte le donne
che mi stanno ascoltando
di riflettere sul fatto che forse
siamo noi stesse la fonte del pregiudizio.
Lo dobbiamo probabilmente
alla nostra insicurezza,
alla nostra scarsa autostima,
ai limiti che ci imponiamo inconsciamente.
Ma se vogliamo che l’algoritmo
sia più forte del pregiudizio umano
dobbiamo fare in modo
che la presenza delle donne nella scienza
sia più numerosa, più sicura di sé
e delle proprie potenzialità
e più visibile nella società.
E giusto per non farci scappare
un ultimo vero marchio di fabbrica,
dobbiamo fare in modo
di crescere ed educare
nuove generazioni di donne consapevoli.
Grazie.